belt had an
achilles injury missed the first six
games for the giants this season
there is a beautiful pitch on a 2-2
curve ball for a called third strike on
brandon belt
on the ground altuve is there oh he
bobbles but he's still with it and he
makes the play
just in time to get crawford for the
final out so
lance starting out well like he did last
start six up six down
yeah uli was raking in oakland he might
be the only guy in that lineup that can
say that
and there's a line drive over the head
of the third baseman solano all the way
down in the corner
so yuli guriel continues his fine
hitting as he is on second base with a
double with one out in the second here's
carlos correa
paul bounces away and yuli will advance
to third
ground ball right side fair ball down
the line rbi single carlos correa
we showed you the ship brandon belt way
off the line yuli scores its one-nothing
astros
mccullers looks sharp so far two
strikeouts through the first two
3-2 is strike three called the fastball
and trump goes down and there's one away
yeah no argument there he knew he'd been
had
and here's your ski
hit hard off the glove of yuli now tube
is there
lance covering in time that'll be the
3-4-1
put out to end the inning lance doing a
good job covering at first base
the bases are loaded for michael
brantley
a little lob into shallow left slicing
and that's going to be a fair ball
that'll be two runs for the astros as
brantley loops a double that just stayed
fair
and that'll bring guriel to the plate
now if the infielders creeping in
webb comes set at the belt here's the
pitch swings and it's a chopper to the
third baseman runner takes off and it
hits bregman
and bounces off the catcher the astros
score again
a bad throw by solano the third baseman
a horrible throw up the line
carlos singled his first time up drove
in a run
on the ground right side dubai will make
the throw to crawford and correa
beats the relay that'll be another run
for the astros
fielder's choice and correa's hustle
makes it a five-nothing game plan for
colors junior normally tough at home has
been outstanding tonight he is only
allowed one base runner that was a hit
batter
hey lance with a nice pick on the
comebacker off the bat of brandon
crawford
that's made it look easy and there's two
away
swing and a miss lance mccullers jr
through five
rolling along the astros lead five
nothing lance for colors
he hit austin slater with a pitch in the
third
and that's grounded sharply left side
into the shift correa shuffles to his
right he has it and throws to first in
time one out
back to the top of the lineup for mikey
that ball into center field mile straw
is back there lance mccullers junior
through six
only base runner has been a hit batter
astros lead five nothing
maldonado is o for two
first pitch to maldonado and that is
hammer down the left field line hooking
will it stay
fair and it does into the landry's
crawford boxes
a home run for martine maldonado and a
six-nothing astros lead
that's number one for martine this year
giants have no hits so far
get on the ground and a base hit
it got under the glove of bregman and
solano's got the first hit of the game
it's a double
solano got out in front of this one and
it just gets
under the glove of alex bregman into
left field seven innings
of outstanding baseball tonight
infielders in now here's brantley one
for three
two two he pulls this one on the ground
to first backhanded by belt
belt was gonna go to first now he throws
home trump
reaches his mit back across the plate
and tags out redick as he comes in with
a foot first slide
well that was that was a different play
and boston state will come up
slater goes the other way hit well at
the wall
out of here slater it's his
third of the road trip and the giants
are on the board
solano drives it to the left and it's
going to be over the head
of tucker yastrensky is going to score
as the ball comes back into the infield
it'll be the second double
in the game for solano and it's six to
two
get on the ground and a base hit that's
gonna score
a pair and now the tying run is coming
up
giants have the tying runs on base and
the go ahead run coming to the plate
a little flare to center field coming on
straw he'll get there
miles straw puts it away things got a
little scary down the stretch but the
astros hold on and snap
a five-game losing streak